Do you remember when I told you about my friend who is getting married soon?
The other day, she told me about this place she visited.
She went there with her fiance...
...and asked this old lady in a red dress some questions;...
...like whether they're perfect for each other...
...and how financially suitable they are for each other, and so on.
Hmm, I guess they basically went there to know about, how shall I put it, destiny,...
...you know, like the future.
The old lady threw a handful of rice and started to mumble some words.
To me, it sounded like a fortune teller, but in a more weird way.
Is that some kind of tradition in Korea?
Partially, I would say so.
One thing that makes Korea very unique is shamanism.
It's quite common to see people, especially those who are engaged,...
...visit fortune tellers for a query.
That being said, I love visiting palm readers.
Anyhow, I watched those female shamans on TV.
They are scary!
It's totally different than the fortune tellers that we usually imagine;...
...you know, an old witchlike lady with a crystal ball.
I do actually remember seeing young people lining up for tarot cards on the streets,...
...like you said, for palm readings.
I've never tried any kind of shamanism before,...
...but now, I'm kind of curious about my future too,...
...so I'm going to try it next time.